know
and then
um
is
um
slow
foreign
um
[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen
councillors and welcome to this meeting
of council
please be seated
before we formally start this meeting i
invite my chaplain father george murphy
of saint anthony of padua stratford to
lead us in prayer father jed
in the name of the father and son and
the holy spirit amen
we pray for
hearts that are open
hearts that will listen
hearts that will debate and discuss
hearts that will seek the very best for
the people of this borough
we ask this through christ our lord
amen
and can we remember this night
the young lad kenny carter was
tragically killed in stretford just a
few days ago we pray for him
and for his family for the young people
of stretford for an end to
knife crime
and hate
eternal rest grants him or lord let
perpetual light shine upon him
may he rest in peace
amen
and father and son and holy spirit
thank you
thank you found jed
apologies i have received apologies for
absence
from councillors brophy chilton and
councillor maitland has had to give
apologies
because of the need to self-isolate
can i ask if anyone is aware of any
other apologies
no
as we are here again in the live center
we do not have our normal voting
facilities
so any votes this evening will be by
show of hands
this meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee meetings
youtube channel
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded
except where there are confidential
items
and this activity promotes democratic
engagement in accordance with section
108 of the local government act 1972
also like on previous occasions when
speaking
members have the option of coming
forward to the table at the front
or if they prefer they can use the
rolling mics
before we begin the minutes up item one
um
i just like to say
i've been reading the council's
constitution
in the week and it talks about
meetings being conducted
in a courteous manner
and i just remind everybody that we've
got strong views
but we can put those strong views in a
courteous manner so hope our members
will observe that this evening
and another just one other little thing
we have talked before about
addressing the mayor and i have asked
people to address me as
mayor or chair i know there are strong
views on that
but i would prefer if people addressed
me as
mayor or chair thank you
the first item is the minutes and noting
that in minute
number one number 52 on the 26th of
november
both the motion and amendment regarding
gmca scrutiny were corrected to reflect
the correct scrutiny committee titles
i moved at the minutes of the meetings
held on the 26th of november 21
and 13th of january 22 be taken and read
as a true and correct record is that
seconded seconded thank you all in favor
aye
announcements
we have all been saddened by the events
which have resulted in a young person
losing their life
in violent and in a violent and
senseless manner
the police i do feel emotional about
them
i have to say i do feel emotional this
boy lived in my ward this occurred
in the area that i represent so forgive
me
the police and our community safety
officers are working hard to address
these issues
and our supporting local communities
our thoughts and prayers go out to all
those
affected by these tragic events
it is with regret that i inform the
council that former councillor david
higgins who was mayor of trafford
2009-2010
sadly passed away peacefully in hospital
on the 13th of january
after a long illness
david represented the brooklyn's ward
and was served on the council i served
on the council for 16 years
from 98 to 2015.
we are awaiting confirmation of the
funeral arrangements and are currently
hazing with the family to determine
their wishes in that regard
as a mark of respect to a former
colleague i invite the council to stand
with me for a few moments and silent
reflection of his memory
thank you everybody
may we take this opportunity to
recognize those citizens and persons
connected with trafford
who were named in her majesties the
queen's new year's honours list
francis rogers of sale was awarded the
cbe for services to local government
reform in the liverpool city region
jaco albert van gaas of sale awarded the
mbe for services to cycling
and cornell grant of old trafford
was awarded the british empire medal for
services to the community in greater
manchester
i am sure you will join with me
to convey the council's congratulations
for their achievements and richly
deserved
recognition
may i make the council aware that dr
barclay attended her resignation as a
councillor affected from the 1st of
january
subsequently it has been agreed under
delegation delegated authority
the council of wetton is appointed chair
of health scrutiny
council of boys is appointed shadow
executive member for adult social care
and councillor evans is appointed as a
reserve on planning and development
management committee
these changes took effect from the 90th
of january and i am now reporting them
to council for information
does the leader of the council wish to
make any announcements this evening
no thank you chad
do the chairs of the scrutiny committees
have anything to announce on behalf of
their committees
no thank you
item three is questions
and seven questions have been submitted
for this meeting and they have been
listed on the council website
for members of the public to view
each questionnaire has the right of a
supplementary question
and shall be put and answered without
discussion we will now take these
questions
in the order that they were received
the first question please is from
councillor myers
thank you mayor
workers dealing with emergency repairs
to gas electricity and water supplies
inter for travelled residents
often have to park their vehicles a long
way from the resident at home
because of local parking restrictions
this can lead to delays in repairing the
falls
increased disruption to residents and
wasted time for workers as they move
back and forth to their vehicles
will the executive member consider
formally giving the same parking rights
to deliveried emergency vehicles as to
blue badge holders and the blue badge
entitlements are set out on the trafford
website
thank you mayor
councillor
executive member for environmental and
regulatory services like to respond
please
thank you for your question council
myers
where trades people are visiting homes
for urgent repairs
for urgent repairs to broken boilers
leaking pipes we would expect them to
park lawfully whatever they can
and to use visitor card systems in
residential permit areas where this
isn't possible parking dispensations can
be applied for with full details on our
website
and whilst usually
these need to be done a few days ahead
of time we can receive requests at
short-term notice
special exemptions also exist for
statutory undertakers carrying out
repairs to gas water or electricity work
given these arrangements i don't see the
need for a blue badge type system at the
present time however
whilst we need our parking wardens to
uphold the parking regulations with
fairness and consistency an element of
common sense is always required
accordingly i have asked that this issue
be highlighted to the parking service
thank you thank you councillor i said
councilor myers do you have a
supplementary
yes thank you mayor um
parking uh assistance parking
operators and common sense don't always
go together
but to avoid wasted time for money
residents and businesses will the
executive member consider adding parking
emergent situations to the formerly
added to be sorry to be formally added
to the six legal grounds for appealing
the penalty charge notice
thank you mayor
thank you for your supplementary council
myers i think we probably need to take
this way and look at and see what we can
do uh where there are circumstances some
of the problems are of course is that uh
in your original question you asked
about livered vehicles but of course if
you're a medium-sized business and you
have a small fleet of vehicles or live
but for the small businessman or the one
the white van brigade with a single
unlived van how would you determine what
has emerged and isn't so i think we
really need to sort of see if there's an
issue here and can look at this further
uh also in the particular circumstances
uh around why you raise this question if
you do not receive a satisfactory
response from the parking services
please do get in touch
thank you
question two come to the boys please can
you put your question
uh thank you mayor um
can the executive member for
environmental and regulatory services
please advise council how many blocked
gullies have been reported by members of
the public and how many have been
cleared in each year from 2017
2018 onwards and in addition can the
member please tell council how many
staff have been employed in the gully
teams and the dig down crews in each of
those years thank you
thank you councillor
thank you for your question council boys
in response in the year 2017 we had
1682 reporting attended in 2018
1786
in 2019
2728 in 2020 2138
2021 2155 and so far in 2022 159 in
addition each year sixteen thousand
gullies are scheduled and targeted for
routine clean in addition to the
reactive calls
that i've attended to the service stroke
contract has two gully crews undertaking
routine and reactive work this has been
in place since 2015 there is a big gang
crew that is contracted in to deal with
underground problems and undertakes
jetting and dig downs during the course
of the year to tackle such issues
thank you thank you
councillor boys do you have a
supplementary yes thank you mayor um
and thank you for your response uh
councillor i said can the executive
member also advise council what plans
have been put in place to work with
united utilities the environment agency
and landowners after heavy flooding to
ensure a more joined up approach is
implemented to allow surplus waste water
to drain away more efficiently in the
future than has been the dreadful
experience in previous years thank you
matt
thanks
thank you for your supplemental question
council boys uh
we are having regular liaison with the
environment agency united utilities etc
a special grouping has been set up to
deal with this following the
the flood events we've had over the past
couple of years the unfortunate thing is
of course is that with climate change we
like to see a lot more of these over
coming years and we have an aging
infrastructure and whilst a lot of the
infrastructure itself can cater uh for
what is uh classed as moderate type rain
when we have something like a month's
reign in a matter of a couple of hours
or so it cannot always cope with that
and and it has to allow some time for it
to settle down so the problems need to
look at is obviously if that can be
improved and that in some case that may
need major investment uh to look at the
whole of the infrastructure but we are
looking at modernizing some of the
systems and working enormously if there
are particular problems that those can
be looked at and addressed and obviously
if you've got particular problems in
your own area do come and talk to us
about it because the facilities are
there and i'm obviously happy to have
those open conversations with you thank
you right thank you councilman i look
forward to the conversation thank you
thank you
question three councillor acton your
question please
thank you chair
uh can i ask the leader to give us give
give the council an update on the
afghanistan relocation and assistance
resettlement scheme in trafford
thank you for your question councillor
acton and i'm pleased to say that to
date three families have been settled in
trafford under the scheme
working with our partners we identified
five properties in the borough to which
those fleeing afghanistan could find a
home three with trafford housing trust
one from onward housing and one from a
private landlord regrettably one of
those properties is still awaiting a
match to be identified from the home
office but we continue to have that
space available as soon as a match is
forthcoming all of the families that
have been accommodated have been
supported by a dedicated support worker
that has been employed using the funding
made available from the a-wrap scheme
they have been assisted to claim
benefits register for gps dentists
register for english language classes
and attain school places for those with
children of school age the support
worker has worked intensively with all
of the families and has assisted with
the practicalities of settling into life
in the uk and we have provided i'm very
proud to say a multi-agency approach to
ensure smooth transition for those
families thank you council acton
thank you councillor western um council
acting do you have a supplementary
question
no just just to say thank you very much
for that comprehensive answer i think
what what's
being done is excellent in terms of
traffic
thank you
question four councillor jerome the next
question please
thank you chair
um traffic council officers have agreed
that communities can opt out of the
weed-spraying um regime where
appropriate why can't we advertise this
on our website as manchester city
council do and promote this as another
element in working towards achieving our
aim of a pesticide-free trafford a
motion passed unanimously in march 2019.
council rat said would you like to
respond
thank you for your question councilman
jerome
as part of the one traffic partnership
contract review there is a piece of work
that is looking at updating our website
to improve communication and information
on service provision with the public and
members we will be updating the website
in the next few months and can therefore
look to update the site to include
information
on how residents can apply to opt out of
weed spraying similar to that that is
offered by manchester in their vicinity
or street stroke area whilst there is
full support
that the move to a pesticide-free
trafford there has to be a response
recognition of some of the potential
consequences of this change this may
include the potential for increased
complaints due to some weeds growing out
of control in some areas causing triple
hazards to pedestrians and damage to the
footwear and highway the transition to a
festive
pesticide free traffic on highway will
require working with members residences
and businesses to have a joined up
approach to weed clearance to keep our
streets safe damage free and weed free
longer term thank you thank you
councillor jerome i'm guessing you've
got a supplementary question i have sure
um what has the con that what has the
council done since june 2020 when the
executive signed off the glycerate youth
and trafford report to further the aims
of the original march 2019 motion which
was to be 100 free of pesticides
can you respond councillor
thank you councillor jerome for your
supplementary question work does
continue of course although being the
pandemic has somewhat slowed that down
and halted a little bit but obviously we
are still
uh looking at trialling products as they
come onto the market and obviously as
things change we'll be looking at doing
that and obviously as i said in the past
and your question refers to where
residents wish to opt out of it we're
obviously willing quite happy to go
along with that but obviously we need to
ensure that the problem isn't dealt with
that isn't an opt-out where nothing
actually happens but we will continue to
do that work and uh and whenever we can
we will actually look to actually move
it completely and we and devin that will
happen at some point obviously we aren't
working to that i can assure you
i'm on to it
thank you please thank you
question five councillor hartley your
question please
thank you mayor it was um great to see
boca court opening recently in timperley
delivering 30 socially rented apartments
the first new social housing
to be delivered in trafford in nearly 10
years
could the executive member for housing
and regeneration tell me how many units
of affordable housing have been
delivered and what proportion of those
will be for social rent in the year
since labor started to lead the council
in 2018 and how does that compare to the
last few years of conservative control
of the council thank you councillor
wright executive member for housing and
regeneration would you like to respond
please thank you chair and thank you
council hartley for your question i can
confirm uh i'm delighted to confirm that
since uh we took charge of trafford uh
59 units of
social rent housing have been delivered
which is 28
of the affordable total that has been
delivered that period
in the four preceding years under
conservative control i can confirm that
eight units of social were delivered
which is two percent of the total
affordable housing delivered during that
period
thank you chair
thank you councillor right do you have a
supplementary council higher than i do
yeah thank you um and could the
executive member confirm the same
figures for units due to complete this
year
and what other council's future plans to
deliver more affordable housing in the
bureau thank you
thank you chairman thank you for your
supplementary council hartley i can
confirm that in the next financial year
we're anticipating 333
affordable units to be
completed
of which 103 of those are going to be
social rent um so the full figure of 333
is nearly as many in a year as we're
delivered in the four years prior by the
conservatives prior to us coming into
power
in relation to what are we doing to
improve
and expand our affordable housing
project we obviously introduced the
affordable housing fund
which provides monies used from
section 106 to
to fund
social housing in this borough or we
have
significantly
reformed the viability process which
means that viability
proposals are publicized now to
uh to anyone that wants to read them
we have made it a major priority of both
of our local and corporate plan and i
can certainly say as the executive
member um that i and will continue to
champion the cause for social and
affordable housing in the for as long as
i'm in the role thank you
thank you councillor ryan
question six councillor morgan please
can you put your question
uh thank you chair could the executive
member for environmental and regulatory
services confirm as part of the one
trafford contra contract seven year
review when is the earliest that
trafford council could theoretically
pull out of the contract
council right said can i ask you to
respond
thank you for your question councillor
morgan
all of the options for termination of
the amy contract have been looked at in
depth in the last two years and options
were considered as part of the
confidential part of the report to the
executive in november 2020. there is no
official
rate clause in the contract
in the absence of any contractual basis
for terminating the contract the council
would automatically be in breach of its
conditions and would be at risk of being
made subject to substantial financial
penalties as have been previously
reported theoretically the council could
terminate the contract at the end of the
seven-year
review review process which is march 22
however
whilst the council could terminate the
contract at that point it would also
need to pay amy's breakage costs and
would need to make provision for
arranging new services which would also
leave the council with significant
financial risk
the contract would continue for a period
of 12 months after determination making
the financial making the final date
march 2023
thank you councilor morgan do you have a
supplementary thank you chair kind of
thank the executive member for that
response and got no further support
thank
you question seven councillor new grosh
the final question please
can the executive member for housing
please inform us what percentage of our
borough's social housing meets or
exceeds the current minimum legal
requirement for its insulation
council right
thank you chair and thank you councillor
new gosh for your question as council
negros be aware we don't own any social
housing in trafford so i'm more than
happy to write to the providers to ask
that question but i don't have that
information at hand at the moment thank
you
that's the new grush
it's a pity that we didn't get the
information there but uh thank you for
that answer and thank you for the offer
for getting the information for me um
i'd like to take the opportunity to
acknowledge the support this council's
given for the energy bills for my
residence 50 pound grants that was very
welcome and i'm asking perhaps for a
meeting to consider other innovative
practical and real ways we can help
insulate and shield them from the coming
energy crisis much like the
winter care packs that were so very very
useful and thanked for so that's my
question
thank you chair more than happy to
facilitate that meeting counseling thank
you thank you
item 4 is a petition
calling for improvements and upgrade to
the playground at stamford park
altringham which received 537 signatures
from addresses within the
borough in accordance with the council's
petition scheme the petition organizer
diane barrett will be right will be
invited to speak to the petition for
five minutes
following which it will be debated by
council for a maximum of 15 minutes
as is the agreed practice for petitions
at council speeches are normally limited
to one member from each of the groups
and since there is only 15 minutes
allowed for the debate each group will
be allocated three minutes and 45
seconds
following the debate the leader of the
council will then summarize the
council's response
if council consents to this arrangement
i will now invite miss barrett to
introduce the petition do we consent to
them
thank you miss barrett thank you it's my
first time
so
take your time
pretty much
um hello everyone my name is diana
barrett i am a local mum of two boys who
are three and six and i live in
altringham i've started a petition
asking trafford council to look into
upgrading the playground at stamford
park and received a lot of support and
feedback from locals and i'm delighted
to get the opportunity to introduce a
petition
stamford park playground is currently
not fit for purpose it is unfortunately
a complete mod bath except after a dry
spell when it is a dirt bit
the play equipment is dated and boring
and there's not a lot of it there's
nothing to do for children past
preschool years
much of the current equipment is also
unsafe i've spoken to several parents
whose children have fallen off the new
wooden structure as the logs get really
wet at this time of the year and really
slippy also the uneven path around the
park makes it dangerous for children on
their bikes and scooters
the park is also completely unsuitable
for any differently abled children
i recently went to the park on a
beautiful sunny afternoon and there was
hardly anyone there which is such a
shame i have printed out some pictures i
didn't realize how many of you would be
here today but if i can
pass a few around maybe um i don't think
we've got time for that miss barrett but
leave them here and i'll make sure the
members
get to look at them
the health and well-being benefits of
play areas are well known and i'm sure
they are accepted by everyone here today
playgrounds are at the heart of a
community and are such an important
gathering space that can benefit
everyone imaginative playgrounds help
children develop social physical
cognitive and emotional skills
a better park would help get kids
outside all year round there are two
primary schools right by the park these
children would really benefit from being
able to catch up with their peers at the
weekend and after school here
spending time outdoors will hugely
improve mental health of all ages and
help combat child obesity an imaginative
park would help establish a lot of
outdoors during early years and also
reduce carbon footprint by keeping
families local
i do realize that it could be difficult
to finance this purely through the parks
and open spaces budget but due to the
enormous knock-on benefits for local
businesses and the area in general i
would hope that there could be other
ways to find the money
some options i have thought of and i
don't know if you welcome my input but
maybe all the new housing developments
could contribute as a better park would
possibly make it a selling point for
them to attract more buyers some of the
local businesses could also sponsor the
new playground or even each equipment
could have a
plaque of the business who sponsored it
we could have a look at national lottery
funds or any
any possible government funds to combat
child obesity and improve mental health
i believe that in addition to the widely
accepted benefits of good play areas
there is a very strong business case for
upgrading the play area in stamford park
and that this should be looked at
differently to a community playground
away from the town center
good playgrounds attract a huge amount
of visitors who spend money in the local
area and not just at weekends i have
spoken to local businesses who were all
in agreement
a good playground in stamford park would
give families another reason to come to
altringham plus it can be easily
accessed by public transport
from all over manchester an improved
park would provide the growing number of
families now living in the town center
with better facilities and make altering
an even more attractive area to live a
new playground with all weather service
and better safer play equipment would
attract visitors year round and keep
locals there due to the current state of
the park
local residents myself included have to
take their kids to expensive play
centers or to excel excellent play areas
funded by other local
councils such as those at bruntwood park
heaton park walton hall knoxford winning
show park just to mention a few
i have taken some pictures
also of a modern playground that i
visited with my family recently and just
to give the council maybe an idea of
what i believe a modern playground in
2022 should look like many thanks for
your time
thank you miss barrett
thank you
councillor patel as executive member for
culture and leisure i invite you now to
respond on behalf of the labour group
thank you
where's the lady thank you for your
petition and for coming here tonight to
present it it takes real guts to come
into this
formal environment and make your case
and i think you've done that really well
it's very clear to me that you and
everyone that signed this petition
really cares about and values
the play area at stamford park
in trafford we have around 80 play areas
ranging in size and popularity stanford
park has a busy playground serving many
families in a densely populated
residential area
we manage investment into our play areas
through our annual capital programme
that is each year a budget is set and
key projects in the borough identified
for some years now the council has been
under tremendous financial pressure
losing millions of pounds year on year
from our funding
within our plans for play areas we
therefore have to prioritize investment
a long time alongside the routine
maintenance that is undertaken i can
confirm that stanford park receives its
fair share of this capital funding
since 2017 well over a hundred thousand
pounds has been allocated to improving
drainage refurbishing tennis and
basketball courts and replacing a
climbing frame we will continue to
invest in stanford park
the equipment in stamford park is not
untypical of a trafford park we replace
individual pieces of play equipment over
time and maintain and repair equipment
until it's deemed to have reached the
end of its lifespan
all our play areas have a weekly safety
inspection
i agree that some of the equipment in
the park is dated but it is safe and
remains well used
under current budget constraints it
would not be possible to undertake a
complete renewal of all the equipment in
a play area of this size
to do so would be to commit to the
entire annual play area budget for
trafford to one park
it's worth noting for the benefit of
members here that the last significant
funding the council received from
government for play equipment was in
2010
over recent years i understand three
projects have been completed to the
surfacing in the play area though it
remains a challenging sight due to the
changing ground levels high footfall and
the extensive tree canopy that covers
the play area
play surfacing can be as expensive as
the equipment itself and it's unlikely
that an affordable solution can be found
that provides a mud-free environment
that said i visited with our green space
officer last week and it was clear there
was a build-up of leaf detritus on hard
standing in the play area which doesn't
help with conditions underfoot we will
therefore be undertaking a deep clean of
the play area footpaths in mid to late
february
many of our parks benefit from having
active friends of parks groups at a
recent meeting of council i incorrectly
stated that stanford park didn't have a
friends group i now understand there is
a group and i would like to apologize
for making this error
i will be working to reset the
relationship between the group the
council and one trafford
speaking with their vice chair earlier
this week they would welcome new
volunteers
and i would like to ask residents who
have signed this petition who are keen
to support the park if they would please
consider getting in touch with the
friends group
all our residents deserve access to a
good park indeed we are discussing later
in this meeting the value that parks
play in our local communities
as the petition presenter clearly
clearly made that case stanford park is
a great park with a long history but i
recognise like other parks in trafford
it's not without its current challenges
i understand that probably i haven't
given you the answer that you hoped for
but i've tried to be positive and open
about how we approach park funding
i would welcome the opportunity to
introduce presidents to the friends of
parks groups and to move forward
developing an ongoing and constructive
dialogue for the benefit of stanford
park thank you thank you councillor
patel well timed
councillor young i believe you're going
to respond on behalf of the conservative
group
trying to improve stamford park is
something that we've been working on for
very many years
the labor route the labor group claims
and we agree
that parks and green spaces play a key
role in promoting good physical and
mental well-being
and over the past year we have had a
number of conversations
with the executive member for culture
and leisure
going to the children's playground for
some inexplicable reason
the seats of the swings in the
children's playground were removed when
the playground was closed during the
lockdown
and in spite of repeated requests these
seats have not been replaced this is a
really sore point as the improvements
made to the children's playground when
the large climbing frame that was
damaged was replaced with a much with a
new much smaller construction of logs
is aimed at younger children and there
is really nowhere in the park for the
slightly older age to ten-year-olds to
play
except for the non-existent swings
i can simply see no reason why such a
relatively
simple request cannot be acted upon
the children's playground is badly in
need of some new equipment as what is
presently available
is not enough for the huge number of
children who use this spark
this last year we've had three
investigative walks around the park to
identify issues raised by residents in
may in july and in november
we identified that there was a flooding
problem in february 2021 as due to heavy
prolonged and wet weather the pond
flooded up to the pathway and the
resultant large puddle remained on the
ground for months before it eventually
drained away we were told in april that
engineers will investigate and produce a
report but we have heard nothing since
and indications remain that more
prolonged wet weather would replicate
this problem
in april
councillor patel agreed to request that
a sign be erected in the tennis courts
in an attempt to restrict the use of the
courts during anti-social hours people
were turning up at 5 30 in the morning
to play games and make a noise
we were grateful for her help and
understanding but sadly we are still
waiting for the sign to be installed
also in april we had to make
representations regarding the
maintenance of the border of the park
this is a mix of a hedge and defense
which is badly broken in a number of
places
while the area under the hedge is badly
in need of clearing and the hedge itself
is also in need of some attention
we are working in close contact with the
friends of stamford park who joined us
on the walk in may and made several
useful suggestions regarding maintenance
schedules and we're happy to go on
working with them and would welcome any
attempts that you can make to increase
membership
in the group because they it could be
very useful
and i think if we all work together
we ought to we may hopefully reach some
good conclusion thank you thank you
council mrs young
i invite councillor new gross to respond
on behalf of the liberal democrat group
thank you miss barrett for bringing this
petition to us and you put the case on
behalf of your neighbors eloquently
might just do that
chat
i need to declare an interest i live in
within five minutes walk of stanford
park and my family and i have
enjoyed this park for years
um
indeed i've done
case work here with the flooding
of those grids and greats with the
united utilities and amy officers myself
unfortunately we still haven't got that
resolved
so the lib dems warmly welcome
investment in all of our trafford parks
indeed thanks to the lib dems in timpani
village we've had investments
of tens of thousands in the last year by
engaging with our officers and thanks to
the exec member
for coming along to walk these parks
i'll pause for a second while the
conservative members note that figure as
they always keen to claim my work in
their leaflets
so
i will absolutely support investment in
our parks and i will be voting in favour
for stamford park to be upgraded if it
can be thank you
thank you councilman
and councillor jerome please for the
green party
thanks chair and thank you uh for
bringing this a
valuable petition to council and when i
was first elected in 2018 i had an early
introduction to these issues a
seven-year-old resident leela
successfully petitioned her school
friends to get the faulty monkey bars
in the play park replaced to be broken
since 2015 and i was proud to help
submit the petition and pass the issue
to hail councillors where stanford park
is located
nothing happened
in june 2018 leela received a letter to
say the equipment had been ordered and
would be replaced in august 2018.
in april 2019 i had to speak to the
chief executive when baffled parents
approached me to say nothing had been
done at all
that same
month leela received an apology and an
explanation it wasn't until june 2020
that the equipment was actually replaced
a five-year battle
the current petition is absolutely
correct when it says the current play
area is in desperate need of an upgrade
it's absolutely correct when it says the
ultra ram community deserves a much
improved playground
parks offer a vital green space for
everyone and the playgrounds within them
are a vital free resource for all
families of tremendous value to health
well-being and enjoyment
councillor welton my ultringham
colleague has been a co-chair of friends
of navigation park and he found similar
problems when trying to get play
equipment replaced there there was no
asset database which meant one traffic
struggled to find suppliers and
guarantee documents
equipment is often downgraded when
replaced there needs to be more
flexibility between small repairs and
large-scale equipment
also these maintenance issues are often
left to friends groups to fight for who
become demoralized when no
improvements happen year after year
in altringham we have also have swings
missing at the cal field and navigation
park and on my visit today to stamford
park they are still missing from there
too
at the cal field we are still waiting
for the promised visit from the
executive member
already council twice
stafford park feels particularly unloved
by this council and numerous problems
need resolving signs by the tennis court
benches needed in the play park fences
needed fixing flooding past services the
list goes on the friends group have told
us that amy don't off don't often don't
communicate in a timely fashion the
feeling from the group that under
funding is making this park more
dilapidated and even more expensive to
fix
many are also asking where did the money
go from the english game series filmed
in the park some clarity on that from
the council would be welcome
my feeling is that if scrutiny are
looking for specific issues to be a be a
critical critical friend to this council
then how many play parks are maintained
would be an excellent subject
how is our money being spent what are
the state of the current contracts and
guarantees around the current play
equipment are residents getting value
for money in terms of the new equipment
that is installed
and yes the green party supports this
petition and would like to see stanford
park with an excellent play area and one
that gets to make the maintenance it
deserves thanksgiving
thank you
finally please will the leader of the
council summarize
for the council
what will happen in the petition
thanks chair and thank you ms barrett
for bringing the petition i don't have a
great deal to add in terms of response
because i think councillor patel set out
the position the position with regard to
um the funding and the work that we will
do to
maintain a fair standard across all of
our parks with the more than 80 with the
80 play areas that we have
um across the borough that said i do
want to
reflect that ms barrett was the only
speaker to set out potential alternative
sources of funding and it's very easy
for members of council to ask for more
money after 12 years now of austerity
that has impacted on this council and
this is the impact of that you know we
were we were told by councillor mrs
young somebody who i respect
tremendously that this shouldn't be a
particularly challenging ask but
unfortunately
when we face a budget gap of more than
20 million pounds year on year as a
result of the sustained cuts
and pressures that we are under these
things do become very difficult to
deliver for our residents that said
there was a suggestion
that we look at
alternative funding sources and of
course if residents and the friends of
stanford park want to look at how they
can do that i'm sure that we would be
very happy to have a conversation with
them about how they could move that
forward
i just want to
respond directly to councillor jerome's
point about the filming that happened in
the park and what i'd say councillor
jerome is that that is currently subject
to a freedom of information request so
it will be um in the in the public
domain if it's appropriate to do so um
fairly soon and i i just think we we
need to reflect that every councillor in
this room receives complaints about
their parks
that there is a huge challenge
and that is the reason that there is a
motion later on this agenda around
funding for parks and green spaces
in the borough because after years of
being starved of funding we do recognize
that this is an area in need of
investment and we are asking for
government support to enable us to do
that thank you jay thank you councillor
weston thank you miss barrett
95 is a report regarding
the appointment of an external auditor
and i will invite the executive member
for finance and governance
to introduce the item and move the
recommendations councillor ross please
thank you mayor i'm very happy to move
this recommendation that was made via
the council audit committee on the 25th
of november that we opt to go into the
national arrangement for appointing an
external auditor
managed by public sector appointments
limited to cover a five-year period from
23-24 as detailed in option three of the
report
thank you is that seconded please
secondary thank you do any members wish
to speak to this report
that's a great idea don't all russian
one no
okay
the report has been moved and seconded
can i ask if the council consents
thank you
the recommendation is carried
item 6 corporate health and safety
report
and i invite councillor ross again as a
responsible executive member to
introduce the report
thank you mayor um covert 19 has
continued to bring significant
challenges for the council in
effectively delivering our key services
whilst ensuring health safety and
well-being of our workforce
during this reporting period as well as
supporting colleagues to work from home
we were supporting the safe
reintegration of staff to our offices
risk assessed covert safe arrangements
were still required even when national
restrictions were lifted in july
the report therefore highlights and
focuses on the key work covert work
undertaken by the aid health and safety
unit provides a brief overview of the
incident data as set out in tables five
and six
provides an update on the ongoing health
and safety delivery including updating
guidance and training
the report has highlighted the continued
work in response to the covet 19
pandemic to protect our workforce and
highlighted work underway in
reintegrating our workforce and
considerations to new ways of working
this collaborative work will continue
and performance detailed in the year-end
report i'm happy to move this and ask
that the council notes this report thank
you thank you councillor ross do any
members wish to speak to this report
okay the report is for information can
it be noted please
thank you
this evening when i moved to the motions
this evening four motions have been
listed on the summons in the order that
they were received
may i remind members that to get through
the business and to get everyone who
wants an opportunity to speak it may be
necessary to limit the time for speeches
therefore please can i ask
everyone to keep their comments concise
and not to avoid repetition
deviation
or hesitation
motion 7a proceeding with the first
motion regarding the cost of living
crisis
i have received notice that it is to be
moved by council of whittam come to the
whitman
thanks chair thanks very much so yeah i
can't promise there won't be any
deviation repetition or hesitation but
i'll do my best
so chair we're facing a cost of living a
crisis in in the uk at the moment that's
affecting people across the whole
country including here in
trafford inflation's already reached 7.5
on the rpi measure and five point four
percent on the the cpi measure but to
put that into more into real terms for
people you know people are expecting
some people will see their fuel bills go
up by as much as 50 in april and food
costs are already up by 10 on the on the
year putting huge pressure on households
up and down the country
in spite of what the government says
wages are not keeping up with those
increasing living costs the triple lot
for pensions has been broken and
universal credit has been cut in april
we face an increase in national
insurance at the same time as seeing a
big hike in our fuel bills
all of this is putting enormous pressure
on hard presses to households and in
particular on those households who spend
a greater proportion of their incomes on
the essential items like food and fuel
costs clothing shelter etc
the backdrop to these pressures is
obviously a long period during which
wages have stagnated and which in work
and out of work benefits have been cut
drastically over over the last decade or
so while decade or more now
this is having real world impacts on
people as people are seeing their living
standards deteriorating
we're in a situation now where millions
of food parcels are distributed to
people across the the country
as a society we should be aspiring to
people being able to save a little bit
of money each month
enjoy the good things in life maybe go
on holiday sometimes celebrate birthdays
but actually we can't even aspire to
everyone in this country being able to
afford the basics
as a council we're doing what we can to
support people who are struggling
we do that in a number of ways as
councillors as members will be aware
through trafford assist
through the council's council tax
support scheme which is one of the most
generous in the country
or supportive in the country i should
say
recently we've been providing support to
as councillor new gross referred to
earlier we've been providing grants to
free school meal eligible families
during the school holiday periods
for many of families that we've
supported with those
payments those grants will have been the
difference between getting into debt and
just about keeping the heads above water
the council's poverty strategy
introduced by this administration is
enabling us to work with partners to
identify ways of alleviating reducing
and preventing poverty
however it is the responsibility of
central government to respond to the
cost of living crisis and to ensure that
everyone in this country including here
in trafford can attain a decent standard
of living
that's why we brought this motion here
to full council tonight we need to put
our weight as elective members behind
calls for action from the government
it's no good government being asleep at
the wheel as more and more people
struggle to meet the basics
the government will point to one of
support measures that have been
introduced during the pandemic without
putting those measures into context they
are they are support packages that are
in context of things like the huge
cuts that have been made to work in age
benefits over the last 12 years
it's no good announcing short-term
limited support packages if we aren't
going to provide a long-term sustainable
solution to the cost of living crisis or
if government are going to give with one
hand and take away with the other
we need to move to a place where the
government recognizes that everybody in
this country requires a minimum income
on which to live off
however the government is
distracted by partygate and is failing
to address the huge increases in cost of
living that we're facing at the moment
as is increasingly the case across a
range of policy areas the labour party
is ready to step up to the plate
suggesting both short-term alleviation
measures to ease the pressure on family
budgets whilst recognizing
the shortcomings of the benefit system
and proposing a radical overhaul
the council must back a comprehensive
approach and call upon the government to
introduce a windfall tax on the oil and
gas companies the revenue raise should
be used to support families with soaring
energy bills and remove vat on domestic
energy bills for a minimum of 12 months
reverse the 20 pound a week to universal
credit
increase benefits by more than planned
in order to reflect the real rises in
the cost of living that are facing
families at the moment
provide long-term dedicated funding to
councils for local welfare assistance
schemes including our excellent traffic
assist scheme here in our borough and
provide permanent support towards meal
cost of free school meal eligible
families during the school holiday
periods
we can already see how some people will
try to spin the cost of living crisis to
serve their agendas they want to use it
to justify cuts to public services and
the scrapping of environmental measures
and they will no doubt try to blame
workers who try to defend their living
standards that is not an appropriate way
forward
backing this motion tonight illustrates
that this council recognized that
recognizes that the cost of living
crisis requires both an immediate
response and a long-term answer iso move
thank you councillor whitton
is that seconded
councillor carter
thank you mayor and thank you councillor
whitman
inflation at a 30-year high
food price inflation at 10 plus
council tax increases baked into the
treasury's planning
and an increase in national insurance
tax and a tsunami of gas and electricity
price hikes breaking in weeks
many people are facing into this with
fear in their hearts and this motion is
about offering some hope
some comfort and some practical help
trafford council as we've heard led by
labour
will do what it can to support families
struggling with the cost of living for
example by proposing a 30 pounds per
week cash award to families entitled to
free school meals this february half
term
putting food into potentially hungry
young stomachs
and i worry about the conservatives
level of comprehension
of the scale of the growing cost of
living crisis
particularly when one traffictory
council has said just two weeks ago that
the proposed tenfold increase in the
warberton bridge toll was not
unreasonable
there are now over 2
000 food banks in britain
for those who found comparisons helpful
that's even more than the number of
pandemics drinks to number 10 reported
so far
our proud and resilient north west
region sees 12 of all emergency food
parcels handed out in britain
poverty's cold face can be seen across
our communities
and the government's current plan to
include a real terms income cut to
households relying on benefits many of
which are already resorting to food
banks to eat sends more than a
metaphorical chill
under their front doors
i can understand the conservative
government being clueless as to how to
begin to address the poverty crisis
presiding over unprecedented
growth in childhood poverty is more
their field of expertise well on this
occasion they don't need a clue
because the clues are in this motion
practical meaningful decent proposals to
help to address the cost of living
currencies
and i hope every member can join in
supporting this motion to show traffic
people facing a real cost of living
crisis that hope
compassion
empathy and practical support
for the bedrocks of british values
there is no more time to waste i ask you
to support this motion and i second it
thank you
thank you councillor carter
the motion has been moved and seconded
do any members wish to speak
councillor carr
so he can keep your hands up and let
cancel a car speak
thank you chair
this motion is sadly absolutely crucial
we've already discussed in this chamber
the awful effects of the cut to
universal credit and now people who were
already struggling are being put under
further pressure
i'd like to underline that this isn't
just affecting those on universal credit
sadly i know i work with a number of
nurses who are having to increasingly
rely on food banks to feed their
children as their income just doesn't
stretch to paying the rent or mortgage
costs energy bills and food bills
poverty changes lives children who are
hungry and who don't have adequate
clothing or who live in poor housing
will do worse at school and face a
lifetime of health inequalities
with a lower life expectancy
i call on all members to support this
motion thank you thank you
councillor hartley please
thank you mayor since 2010 we've seen
tour austerity stagnant wage rises
increasing child poverty and more
in-work poverty many families are
already having to make the choice
between heating and eating whether to
put food on the kitchen table or to buy
the children new school shoots
a cost of living crisis is already a
reality for many families and these
problems are of the government's own
making
but it's set to get much worse in april
we'll see a 51 increase in the energy
price cap it will add 700 pounds to the
average energy bill
not everyone can shop around for the
best deals the poverty premium means
that those in poverty cannot access the
best tariffs
so the price cut rise we saw in october
resulted in an average 139 pounds extra
on the average bill but 153 pounds extra
if you run a pre-payment meter
the latest rise will hit lower income
households the most as well after
housing costs for a single parent
low-income family the share of income
they'll need to spend on energy will
rise from 15 to 25
and for a single person household the
rise will be from 33 to 54
a large part of this increase is due to
the rise in wholesale gas prices but
tory governments of recent years have
left us poorly prepared they've failed
to invest in renewable sources fail to
invest in nuclear new nuclear technology
they've closed much of our long-term gas
storage facilities and they fail to
intervene in an energy market that's
been failing people for years
it's a similar story with the cost of
food
five percent inflation won't be familiar
to many working families shopping for
food
this was well illustrated by jack monroe
this week
she recorded price increases she'd seen
over the last 12 months in the cost of
the cheapest brand of essential staples
cheapest pasta rising 29p to 70p
chippies rice from 45p to one pound bred
up from 45p to 58p
all of these and other price increases
are many times more than five percent
a shortage of 100 000 hdv drivers extra
paperwork and full custom checks at the
border a 34
vacancy rate in crop picking 15 to 20
vacancy rates in food manufacturing
all of this was predicted
as was the increase in fruit prices
and what's been the government's
response to this havoc that they've
wreaked it's been to decrease the
incomes of the poorest people
from april there'll also be a rise in
national insurance contributions
i don't believe people who say it's a
rise of 1.25 it's not it's an increase
in over 10 percent in the contributions
people will have to pay
inflation is predicted to reach 5.1
but the government will only upgrade
benefits by 3.1
that alone will see 100 000 people
pulled under the surface into deep
poverty
seven in ten of those people will live
in households with children
half will be in working households
and of course the government have
already caught universal credit by 20
pounds a week i measure the tories in
this chamber refuse to condemn
the government should have acted a long
time ago to prevent this crisis there's
plenty they could still do now but they
do nothing we have a government devoid
of integrity and devoid of ideas a
government lacking accountability and
lacking competence we have a prime
minister who i would say is not just
asleep at the wheel but too busy
planning around to even get in the car
and start the journey towards anything
resembling responsible leadership
enough is enough the government must
start now to stop millions more being
plunged into poverty thank you thank you
councillor blackburn would like to come
in
thank you
we all live in trafford and we represent
our residents and
we all know people who have
different
lifestyles some have more money a lot
more money than other people
as it's always been and it will probably
stay like that for many generations to
come
and
i think there's um an idea that
if you are a conservative councillor
that
you
live in a bubble and that you don't know
anything about about residents it's not
true
and
we've not all come from um
well-heeled backgrounds
this isn't that's that's that's that's
not true you know we've we've all come
from sort of different backgrounds
um
i can see a few people smirking so smirk
away um can i just
point out a couple of things um
the rising cost of fuel purchased by the
energy companies is not only borne by
you uk companies but it's worldwide
and the cost of fuel is is going to
become
dreadful and it's the same for everybody
we all we all pay for gas and electric
unless you live in an all-electric house
um but
one of the things about the fuel costs
is that part of the any energy bills
cover um the um the advancement of clean
energy
um it goes towards paying for equipment
such as wind farms both at london sea
and we obviously all want
um
to be cleaner energy in the future i
know i know i definitely do
um
the
national insurance that is mentioned um
is is
um you won't be paying it until it's
980 pounds which isn't a great deal of
money and
yes it's um you know that there is going
to be but we've got to remember that the
national insurance pays for our nhs and
it pays for lots of things and without
us getting the money in then we're not
going to be able to help people
generally
and can i also point out that um
i can't quite understand where you're
saying it's a cut the universal credits
uplift was for a limited
time with an end date
it wasn't
it wasn't sort of an extra thing that
was going to last forever
and the benefit returned to its original
amount and the benefit was increased
so
during the you know the first lockdown
to help out residents that were you know
in receipt of that
um
i'm not defending energy companies at
all for the amount that they're charging
residents um because it it's it's going
to be very very difficult
and
you know there will be
hard choices to be made
and i i understand that you know
growing up in in a home where you know
we didn't have central heating yeah we
didn't have we didn't have them uh loft
insulation you know there wasn't
anything like that
um and
i'm not saying that we should go to go
back to anything like that of course we
shouldn't and we're expecting um our our
lives to be better than 50 60 years ago
and that's what we want and we want
better for our children and
grandchildren
but
um
i i just feel that there's got to be
an understanding that that money has to
be raised for you know for everybody in
in our societies
and
it's you know it's not it's not going to
um it's not going to sort of go down
well with with with the labour group
and but i just i just really feel that
it's it's important that we do
raise as much money as we can
through um through through national
insurance and income tax
because otherwise there's
nothing happens and there's nothing you
know for everybody in
society thank you thank you councilman
um
we are running late and i'm conscious
we've got other motions to discuss this
evening important motion i need to get
through the business i'm just going to
remind you i've got four i think i've
got four speakers left councillor evans
councillor wright councillor jerome and
did i miss some councillor dagnold
councillor oxford as well
um now people are starting to put their
hands up and we
what i'm gonna have to do
we have to restrict it with respect we
have to we have to restrict you to two
minutes and i will be sticking to that
i had four speakers
previously and now it's jumped up to
eight
so everybody's gonna have to stick to
two minutes on that i'm gonna allow
eight people to speak it's going to be
two minutes each okay
council oxford please
um inequality in the uk continues to
rise with many struggling to meet even
their most basic needs
how can those on a lower income be
expected to manage faced with a 50
increase in energy bills seven percent
increase inflation a one point two or
five percent increase in national
insurance and all this without the
safety net of a benefit system that's
fit for purpose
our middle income families are expected
to major to spend just six percent of
their income on energy bills
low-income families could spend as much
as 54
and as already highlighted jack monroe
has identified that while a ready meal
has hardly increased in price since last
year the basic food item of a bag of
rice has increased by as much as 344
percent
it's truly shocking that those in
hardship our elderly those with
disabilities our carers
are faced with making this choice
between eating and heating with the
increasing reliance on degrading and
humiliating food banks which remove the
empowerment of choosing healthy options
it really doesn't need to be like this
if only the tory government had the
foresight to plan ahead and were
committed to protecting the vulnerable
rather than offering peacemale measures
which only paper over the cracks
still heavily relying on fossil fuels
produced overseas for example
rather than rapidly investing in the
renewables we so urgently need
this government continues to maintain
its obsession with the vagrant of the
market in its priority to subsidise
profit-making corporations rather than
supporting community-led energy projects
retrofitting and moving towards public
ownership of energy
based on providing a public service
rather than creating profit we so
desperately need a sustainable energy
system that is more resilient to the
inevitable crises ahead of us
surely this is the time to start
in the absence of a meaningful cohesive
strategy from the tories this motion
calls on the government to introduce
some urgent measures needed to protect
our residents from this frightening
increase in basic living costs which i
urge you to support thank you thank you
councillor evans
two minutes please
thank you chair
we have here a motion from our labor
group calling on the government for more
funds
national issues that this council has no
control over we have elected mps and
this labor group has their own mps to
champion them for their thoughts
but this council's concern is selective
isn't it chair
we are calling here for extra funding as
prices rise while our own council leader
supported by labor in this chamber and
across gm is introducing a punitive
charge that will hit the poorest of the
self-employed
the traders forced to use their vans as
personal transport the motor home owner
that uses their vehicle to drop their
child to school hardworking tax payers
chair
we have sole traders our tilers florists
car valiters new businesses struggling
to get going all targeted by council of
westerns and andy burnham's
ill-thought-out sham of a clean airplane
with zero no2 exceedances here in
trafford for the last five years yet we
blunder on blaming the government
government duplicitous in their support
for the most vulnerable
so our group will not be supporting this
motion chair
just a few things this government has
done to support families with their
household bills
launching a 500 million household
support funds so local authorities can
get help
those on lowest incomes with food and
utility costs investing 200 million per
year to continue the holiday activity
and food programme providing healthy
food and enriching activities for
children on free school meals keeping
the energy price cap in place this
winter helping 15 million uk households
save up to 100 pound a year on their
heating and energy bills conscious of
time chair i'll finish there but our
group will not be supporting this motion
thank you councillor rights please
thanks chair i'll be i'll be brief given
the time constraints over four billion
pounds in covid business grant fraud
written off by the chancellor 37 billion
pounds spent on test and trace dodgy
money for decorating boris is flat tory
mps family firms giving lucrative
coverage contracts and of course
champagne parties in lockdown in downing
street any tory that tells you that
their government can't afford to tackle
the cost of living crisis is frankly
lying to you thank you thank you
councillor jerome please
thanks chair i'll shorten this not so as
not to repeat what others have said but
the um the green party has also called
for a five-point plan to tackle the
growing hardship fell by many
and provide an emergency grant to
homeowners landlords and councils to
fund immediate installation improvements
to those most at risk of fuel poverty
extend winter fuel payments with an
additional 320 pounds
make the polluters pay by introducing an
immediate windfall tax on oil and gas
and company profits invest in domestic
energy security by massively ramping up
onshore and offshore wind and solar
scrap the national insurance increase
and abolish the lower rate of
ni on higher earnings
and we will be supporting this motion
and recognize that short-term measures
are urgently needed to help families and
others that face poverty but we also
need urgent long-term measures to tackle
our climate crisis which also help those
in need a carbon tax would be a critical
lever to help shift the uk towards a
clean green economy
tax yield from that would help deliver
dividend by funding cheap and accessible
public transport free home insulation
and yes a universal basic income
and
as one x tory voter told me on the
doorstep this weekend gone this
government just doesn't have the
understanding
all the ability to make the rapid and
big structural changes we so desperately
need in this country thank you chair
thank you
and councillor dagnol please
i am going to be really really brief i
just wanted to mention um i'll make
reference to council blackburn's
statement this evening
um
she basically suggested that some people
have more money and that's probably
never going to change and i just want to
say exactly and that's why we're here
fighting your opinion that these things
are inevitable and an aspect of life we
don't believe that we're not pull up the
ladder tourists like you are councillor
blackburn we determine that we want to
make a difference to people's lives here
in trafford where they are struggling as
they are elsewhere and we are every bit
within our right to stand here in this
chamber and support those residents that
we represent thank you
thank you
councillor new gross did you indicate
you want to speak
thank you chair
the pressing cost of living crisis has
been on the minds of my residents for
months now school gate conversations
have worried parents unable to heat
their homes and struggling to feed their
children
these are the most vulnerable residents
being affected the most
my question earlier sought to find some
immediate practical help we as a council
can provide
if anything this motion doesn't go far
enough
lib dem leader ed davey first called for
robin hood tax on the energy companies
um we also have called for a doubling in
the warm home discount which um as boris
johnson will not know is 130 pounds a
year not a week
we also would wish to double the winter
fuel allowance and we're calling for a
new 10-year home insulation scheme which
is both green and it will help on this
crisis
i'm also as council whitman's deeply
concerned that the conservative
government is totally distracted helping
police with their inquiries
the lib dem strongly support this motion
and wish it could go further thank you
thank you
councillor acton please
thank you chair
i just want to refer to council
blackburn where she says
she knows her community
and you want to
you want better for
your grandchildren
but we all want that
and the trouble is you supported
austerity for the last 12 years
and
the cost of living crisis within this
country
is down to successive conservative
governments which you
and your party have supported
right behind
that
and the last 12 years quite frankly of
tory rule has been an absolute disaster
in that time people have lived through
stringent austerity measures
forced onto the country and here in
trafford
where the poorer get poorer and the
wealthy get richer and that is wrong
that should not happen
and we have fought that every step of
the way
unfortunately the conservatives have not
done that in this chamber they've let
that go
unanswered and it's been an absolute
disaster and i think conservative
cowswood in trafford
need to take responsibility
for this
crisis that we have in the economy
now and for people
ordinary people who are living their
lives
and
for the actions that they have given uh
where they just ignore the fact that
austerity has been the worst thing that
could have happened for the last 12
years thank you mr mayor thank you
i think that's all the speakers
i'm going to ask
i'm going to push on councillor thomas
we're running late i'm going to ask um
councillor whitson as i write to reply
come to the whitton
thanks chad i'll i'll be briefing the
interesting interests of time so i won't
i won't respond to everything that was
said by colleagues but obviously welcome
the vast majority of comments that were
made
um during the last 20 minutes or or so
just just to to go back to where we
started though i think i do think
councilor evans was guilty of deviation
there he seemed to give his speech there
for all of the motions that's coming
later so there'll be repetition there as
well of course in a few moments time
um in terms of just i think with in
terms of council of blackburn in terms
of what she was saying somewhere within
there was quite an eloquent kind of case
for tax and spend and redistribution and
it's not unusual for conservative
politicians to come over to the labour
side at the moment so perhaps perhaps
he's in their own party there
there's a space there if you want to
come over
um i would i mean this is i wouldn't
accuse any conservative
conservative councillors in trafford
including council blackburn have been in
a bubble
um and we also heard from councillor
evans he was sort of critical of us
bringing you know nationalism issue to
the chamber as if it doesn't affect our
our residents the point is this what we
ask of the conservative group on traffic
council whether it's on issues around
poverty and living standards whether
it's on council cuts we need your
support to put pressure on your
government
so we can do something about the damage
they are doing year after year both in
terms of people living in poverty but
also in terms of public services and
that's what we ask of you
these issues are absolutely relevant to
us here in trafford and it's really
important that we bring them to this
chamber and we make our voices heard and
we ask you to make your voices heard
because it's your government's doing
this
this damage final point from me really i
think it's just really important and i
did allude to this but i think other
speakers said it a bit more clearly is
it's all very well pointing to one-off
measures like the the hardship fund
that's been introduced but but you've
got to put those things into context the
value of that hardship fund over the
winter to greater manchester it's around
20 million pounds or so the cost of
greater manchester of the 20 pound a
week cut to universal credit
is worth over 300 million pounds to
greater manchester so you have to put
these things in context it's no good
giving a little with one hand and taking
a lot away with the other so thanks
everyone for your contributions and i
hope everyone will support this motion
tonight thank you councillor whitson
i will now put the motion to the vote
all those in favor of the motion please
show
is it okay yeah hands down and those
against the emotion please sure
okay thank you hands down any
abstentions
okay that motion is carried that
motion's carried
motion 7b
is regarding traffic's parks and open
spaces and i invite councillor patel to
move this please come to the hotel
thank you chair
we should all be very proud of our parks
and green spaces in trafford by bringing
this motion i do not want to paint a
picture of despair but rather i wanted
to highlight the important role that
parks and open spaces play in our
communities environment and well-being
whilst being realistic about the
challenge that we face
we all know as local councillors how
important parks and green spaces are to
our residents indeed i deal regularly
with casework inquiries from all parties
i also regularly meet people who recall
the days when our parks had park keepers
the provision of which would be
inconceivable within current budgets
this very regular conversation i have
leads then to a discussion about the
changing nature of our parks and the
impact impact of long-term cuts to local
government funding
i don't think there has ever been an
open and honest national debate about
the shrinking of local government
we may disagree politically on the
merits of this but we all know that our
residents have noticed and that it's the
council that is the public face of these
cuts and changes
would like to take some time to thank
our friends of parks groups
they vary in scale activity and focus
but all bring something amazing
from fundraising gardening litter
picking community events events and more
they make a real difference
it's not always an easy relationship
with our friends of parks groups
frustrations over maintenance investment
decisions and the contractual
arrangements we work within can be
sources of tension
i want to put on record that the hours
and hours of volunteer time they put
into our parks and green spaces is
gratefully acknowledged by traffic
council we really couldn't do without
you
i understand the introduction of the amy
contract proved to be a shock though i
am confident that in the last few years
that the relationship between the
council one trafford and friends groups
has become more open and constructive
we will ensure that the voice of friends
groups is heard within the amy contract
review process
i would also like to thank one trafford
and council officers and our operatives
on the ground it's not an easy job
expectations are high budgets are
limited but they provide a dedicated and
knowledgeable team who like the friends
of parks groups make a difference to
communities
i would just like to finish off by
sharing a good news story which
demonstrates our flexible and ambitious
approach to green spaces we recently
received this feedback from trafford
ramblers association about the welker
country park project delivered in
collaboration with one trafford city of
trees the conservation volunteers and
viola
i came across wall acre country park
very recently off ambleside road flixton
it was brilliant paths improved and
marked routes for leisure walks
interpretation boards and the whole area
given an identity of wallach country
park well done to all involved
we are doing some great work in our
parks and green spaces but face a
fundamental challenge of scale over the
next decade in maintaining and providing
infrastructure for our parks and green
spaces
footpaths park buildings drainage play
areas are under pressure we remain
committed to our parks capital programme
we'll continue to look for external
funding opportunities but what we also
need is recognition from government that
in a crowded
field of demands parks matter thank you
thank you councillor patel is a motion
seconded
councillor gilbert would like to come
forward
i'm delighted to have the opportunity to
second this important motion we cannot
underplay the importance of our
fantastic green spaces and parks and the
impact they have on our mental health
and well-being these spaces came into
their own during the pandemic with
anecdotal evidence telling us the number
of visitors increased significantly
i asked my mum friends what the parks
meant to them and i was almost taken
aback by how passionate they were my
friend a primary school teacher from
sales said being postnatal in a pandemic
was hard and the new baby bubble
actually felt like prison some days i
remember quite vividly the warm weather
of the first lockdown and being able to
have an hour of exercise and even just
walking in the local parks felt like
paradise
a second friend said i'm not sure how i
can put into words how essential i find
green spaces especially safe local ones
i can take my kids to i had my second
child at the beginning of the pandemic
and they were the only thing keeping me
sane visiting the park was the highlight
of my days actually i was in the park
when i referred myself to trafford
mental health for help with postnatal
depression she then went on to say how
she couldn't fault their brilliant
service
there is sterling work done by all the
friends of groups who look after our
parks and i'd particularly like to note
the great events run by the friends of
ashton on mersey park in my ward but
they can't do everything they need
investment and updating and in the midst
of a cost of living crisis parks remain
accessible and inclusive i remember
having nothing left after paying child
care when my eldest went to nursery and
there were many times i couldn't afford
a soft play center the cinema or a trip
to a cafe but my daughter was still
absolutely thrilled to go to the park
this will become the case for more and
more parents an investment in parks and
green spaces is like free healthcare and
education a sign of a civilized society
i call on all members to pass this
motion
thank you councillor gilbert
um i received notice of an amendment to
this motion and i'm about the amendment
to be moved by councillor jerome
and can we be as quickly as possible
jerome
thanks chair i wanted to welcome this
motion there is much we agree with when
discussing the issue of park maintenance
with officers that the budget of the
parks is often described as tiny or
minuscule in terms of the challenge it
shows the challenges that the council
faces under the weight of austerity
this motion also highlights the great
work that our friends groups do across
the borough in altering them we have
many such groups that are doing
unbelievably great work the friends team
at john lee park have led the way in
showing what such groups can achieve we
also have dedicated groups in navigation
park cal field to mention a few and
smaller greens standing up for green
spaces like the friends of barrington
green the crescent in norfolk brow and
more
however the green group have put a small
friendly amendment into this motion
we've seen during the lockdown how green
spaces have become even more vital for
all the people that enjoy the outdoors
in leisure and safety
when sport was suspended in notre dame
golf course this this became an
invaluable space for people to get
outdoors get exercise and fresh air it
was a great importance to health and
wellbeing in the covert crisis 0.7 in
this motion shows this council is trying
to protect green space in some areas by
working with the fields of trust to
secure future the futures of the
williams roadside turn moss and
crossfitfootbridge in perpetuity
this protects these spaces legally with
a deed of direction a binding legal
agreement forever that is recorded with
the land registry protecting parks and
green spaces via the local plan is also
welcome but only provides protection in
planning terms and only for the plan's
life cycle of 15 years
therefore is there a role for scrutiny
or executive to review whether we could
extend the field of trust protection
further it provides legal certainty in a
world that can change fast politically
and would also provide residents with
the reassurance that their communities
and green spaces are protected and
valued by this council we'd love to see
those ultra
green spaces protected in this way
thanks chair
thank you councillor jerome councillor
wilson will second
thank you very much for that and the
amount the amendment has been moved and
seconded do any members wish to speak to
the amendment
anybody else i've got council of western
anybody else
in the audience come to the new crush
two people okay
councillor weston please can you two
minutes please come needed chair thanks
we will support
the amendment but i am mindful and want
to place on record that past experience
has taught us that it requires a
significant amount of work to go through
a field interest process so i'm putting
a marker down now that i will need to be
assured through that scrutiny work that
this can be done quickly efficiently and
effectively um before i would be minded
to to support this if it came to
executive thanks chad thank you there
was somebody else
come to new grosh
yes well thank you very much for that
chair
i also want to just take time to thank
our friends of parks
for example friends prickling lodge that
council jane broke founded
the broomwood community
partnership that looks after broome
parks they do a vital job and and
really without them we will be lost so
thank you
we are going to be supporting this
amendment also it's actually lived on
policy and uh we welcome it um we look
forward to it being implemented thank
you thank you councillor chulking went
to speak
thank you charlie keep this brief um we
support the amendment uh it's it's
positive we need to protect these spaces
as best we can
and i welcome everything that's been
said tonight thank you councillor patel
you have the right to respond
uh thank you everyone for your support
and uh thank you to all the members that
support their friends of parks groups
again they do some really great work
thank you thank you councillor patel
um
council welton you want to come in
if you can be as quickly as possible
carlton wilson is a friendly motion
everybody's happy
yeah i just wanted to ensure our leader
that i think this doesn't have to be
done overnight in liverpool the
community's most lacking green spaces
are seeing their provision protected
first alongside the city's landmark
parks and other green spaces will be
added over time there's also a measure
of flexibility on use of space provided
by the scheme but with the backstop that
anything significant would be approved
by the trust so i hope that gives
members reassurance thank you
okay
i've got no disagreement so i'm going to
take that an affirmative from everybody
can i hear a positive response
thank you
motion 7c the next motion regarding the
greater manchester clean air plan
is
you want me to do that formally well we
haven't actually
okay
since we have already had substantial
discussion i propose
i propose without any further debate to
move to the vote on the substantive
motion
thank you
the next motion scene regarding the
greater manchester clean air plan is to
be moved
by the leader of the council
council western thanks chair i will be
briefly moving the motion as i suspect i
may wish to say rather more
um at the end of the debate but just to
make clear
um two members that this is effectively
an endorsement of the of the position
taken um by the gm clean air committee
last thursday to ask for a pause
to the opening of funding for the second
phase of the clean air plan scheduled to
open
this week actually or rather on monday
at the end of january
it is a recognition
that given the changing conditions in
the supply chain and the impact that
that has had on
the second hand market in terms of
compliance fleet also particularly for
lgvs
that this could potentially mean that
our ability to achieve compliance in
terms of nitrogen dioxide emissions at
the roadside is impacted because the
financial support package that was
secured last year not incidentally all
of the money that we had asked the
government for for the record
only some of it but nonetheless the
financial package
that we secured
may not be sufficient to enable impacted
businesses residents etc to transition
to clean a fleet clearly if that is the
case and people are not able to
transition to clean a fleet instead of
driving compliant vehicles they will be
driving non-compliant vehicles the idea
of this scheme is not that people pay
the daily charge it is that they are
supported to not do so and it does
appear
from the evidence that we have as a
result of the work that myself and andy
burnham commissioned at the end of last
year and that the financial package is
not
sufficient to ensure that we can avoid
that
therefore we are asking the secretary of
state
to enable us to pause the opening of the
funds because unfortunately we are in a
position where greater manchester can
not do that in isolation and only the
secretary of state can make those
changes so i'm hoping this this won't be
controversial actually i think we all
want to be solution focused with where
we're at with this
and i hope that it will have the support
of colleagues to ensure that whatever
plan we end up with as a result of this
work it is one that is meaningful
cleaned up our air but does so in a way
that is fair to all those impacted and
needing to transition their vehicles
thank you chair thank you councillor
weston councillor new is to second the
motion counseling
thank you mayor
air pollution contributes to dementia
alzheimer's disease asthma heart disease
copd lung cancer and emphysema it
construct growth and polluted air
impacts life from when we are in the
womb with some scientists suspecting
that air pollutants can cause birth
defects in greater manchester each year
1200 people die due to poor air quality
in 2018 the government advised all 10 gm
councils that there were illegal levels
of nitrogen dioxide pollution at the
roadside in each of our councils
responsibility for dealing with this was
passed from central government directly
to local government and has been done as
as has been done across the country to
other areas with the same pollution
problems
due to the sheer size of the clean air
zone anxiety and worry has reached
levels of great anger
anger aimed at the mayor of greater
manchester and at the leaders of all 10
gm borough councils
the reality is and will remain that the
conservative government has attempted to
implement these measures by expecting
local people
and businesses to pick up the bill to
comply with the government's legal
direction by retrofitting non-compliant
vehicles at their own cost
this is hugely unfair expectation and
for many thousands of businesses sole
traders and individuals it is a
financial impossibility
people are at breaking point food bank
use is higher than it's ever been the
rise in the cost of living is impacting
working families massively as things
currently stand
the prospect of daily charges to simply
be able to work is too much for average
workers to deal with
the impact of this on mental health
after the challenges of the last two
years can not to be underestimated
the only way air quality will improve is
if businesses and individuals can access
the financial support needed to upgrade
their vehicles to be compliant with
legal emissions standards the current
agreed level of funding is woefully
insufficient
it is urgent that the conservative
government engage in discussions with
mayor andy burnham and the leaders of
the 10 local authorities to bring about
the changes vitally needed to make this
scheme fair for everyone
the funding rollout must be paused and
reconsidered
our councils are legally obligated to
achieve complaints in terms of nitro
dioxide emissions but without the
crucial financial support in place and
the measures put forward in this motion
it is fear that the clean air plan will
be unsuccessful in this aim and our
residents fear having their lives
destroyed by financial ruin
this is a critical situation
thank you mayor thank you councilman you
um can i just remind everybody that this
is available on the youtube channel the
council i've got a webcast taking place
as we speak
and there really isn't any need to film
people individually i'm advised that you
are allowed to film using your mobile
phone but if you do go on the youtube
channel you can see it
in all its glory at home in the comfort
of your home
um
i received notice of an amendment to
this motion and invite the amendment to
be moved by councillor coggins council
coggins
thank you mayor and um i wanted to start
by um thanking the many members of the
public who have come tonight uh to uh to
to to listen to this motion we
appreciate you coming and giving up your
time
um
it is really outrageous that the big car
companies like volkswagen and others
have made millions out of swindling
their emissions tests while these very
small business owners who are often
providing really essential business
services here in in greater manchester
are being impacted in fact they're being
impacted and they're suffering from a
double whammy
and first of all people like you who
drive from for a living are one of the
groups who are most at risk from air
pollution
and secondly
the government has consistently provide
consistently failed to provide a decent
hardship fund to help you make the
transition to cleaner safer vehicles
something that we in the green party
have consistently called for
now i can see that now supply problems
have added to the problems and we
understand that oppose to the funding
scheme is necessary
we need to take this time to ensure the
government step up and provide the
funding that you so desperately need to
give you to give you clean healthier
lives and to give us all cleaner air to
breathe
but what must not happen is any delay to
the implementation of the scheme
we have waited years for this and we
will have to wait years more for it
actually to take effect and we have to
remember this is talking about clean air
but it's not actually really going to
give us clean air this is just bringing
us up to legal levels of pollution only
on one of the many many pollutants that
we're struggling with
so we really must ask government to step
up and stop asking our hard-working
drivers like this to choose between
their health and their livelihoods
this amendment also asks us to think
about the many other things that the
council could be doing to help us get
cleaner air
there are all things within the remit of
this council especially working with
partners like tfgm and they will all
bring us cleaner air better well-being
and also help to protect our climate
measures like increasing our support for
cycling and walking 20 mile per hour
speed limits wherever people live a
rapid expansion of the school streets
initiatives
um
support for electric cargo bikes and
vehicle sharings things that are working
really well in other countries that are
not rocket science that we could just
step up and follow action on idling is
another crucial issue often raised by
residents who live near schools affected
by um school buses idling and the three
level crossings that we have in the
borough
the lives lost the miscarriages
the dementia and other illnesses caused
by this invisible killer
are avoidable
we must get the decent support that you
people need to help our small businesses
to make the changes that will give you
better health that will give us all
better air quality and will help our
city run more smoothly
but the scheme must also proceed on time
and we must do much much more thank you
thank you councillor plugins um
councillor jerome will second the
amendment
thanks chad i'll be very quick um i
think we we can't underestimate the the
scale of this problem and if we look
back to where it started it started with
the death of nine-year-old ella ladoo
kissy deborah who died when she was nine
living on the south circular road in
london
and it was her mother who fought for
um air pollution to be recognized and
made a material contribution in terms of
the effects of air pollution and we know
air pollution kills
35 000 people plus per year it
contributes to many other deaths um
especially as people get older with a a
myriad of different illnesses so this is
a really critical thing that we must
solve and it's it's
important that the government take
responsibility that they create the
incentives
and
help to create their transition by
funding people properly to be able to
move away from dirtier vehicles but
there is many cheap things that we can
do also which councilor coggins has
mentioned
um one of the simple things to do would
be to implement 20 miles speed limits
where people live we've brought this to
this council many times it's funny that
labour and conservatives support it when
they're out of power when they're in
power they seem to ignore the cause of
twenties plenty but it's proven to make
a difference but um please do support
this amendment it's a good one and i
think uh it'd be great if it was passed
tonight thanks jeff thank you the
amendment has been moved and seconded do
any members wish to speak to the
amendment
let me keep your hands up and let me
mark everyone so i don't miss anybody
anybody else counsel a car
is that it yeah okay
councillor coynes
and council blackburn councillor morgan
councillor mersa would you like to go
first please
i have to restrict you to one minute i
think one minute 30 seconds please
councilman i'm sorry about that but we
are running late
thank you mayor each and every one of us
here today agree on one matter
and that matter is that we all desire to
live
in an environment with clean air we'd
like this for ourselves our families the
residents of our respective wards and
the borough at large
but attempting to gain such a goal comes
at an economic cost
this motion does properly recognize the
economic challenges and consequences of
the clean air zone
however we cannot support the motion as
drafted and we oppose the green party
amendment
the motion is inadequate insufficient
and yet again misses the point
what is that point
the point is that in terms of nitrogen
dioxide exceedences according to clean
air greater manchester data trafford has
not breached air quality levels since
2016
and my source for that is the gmca's air
quality
annual status reports the sasrs
and so if we are genuinely concerned
about the economic and financial impact
on our hard-working self-employed
individuals
and our precious small businesses
what we ought to be doing
is calling for the suspending of the
caller of the greater manchester clean
air final plan
initiating an independent investigation
into that uh final plan
and calling upon the secretary of state
secretary of state's review to look to
remove trafford from the clean air zone
or at least remove the majority of the
borough from the clean-out zone in light
of the uh lack of exceedences thank you
thank you thank you
um
councillor hines please
thank you may um i did actually want to
speak to the main motion um but i can
speak at this point if that's okay and
i don't want to repeat what everybody
has already said
about
the the real requirements for the clean
air zone and from a health perspective
um
but what i do want to say is that it is
clear that tensions are running really
really high over this
and i think that's a clear indication
actually that we need this to be
resolved and in order to do that we have
to have um government come to the table
and work with us on this
and that's what we're calling for and we
would urge you all to support the labour
motion and because that is the way to
achieve that and
the government has a real responsibility
to ensure that its policy is deliverable
and in light of the global supply chain
issues caused by the pandemic
our motion tonight clearly sets out the
requirement for government to urgently
review this it is essential they come to
the table to work with us now and to
ensure that businesses
are supported to comply and i do hope
that you will all support the labor
motion tonight thank you man thank you
councillor heinz council robins please
thank you chair
just hang on
come on cancel jerome
i'm just wondering whether members
should be speaking to the amendment
yeah that's what they are doing
yeah in the last speech i
don't think numbers i think i think
council hines acknowledged that
councillor jerome to be fair members
should be speaking to the amendment now
thanks joe
if you'd like to speak to the amendment
councilor evans
thank you chair um the labour motion
coupled with the agreement green
amendment
is a case of more smoke and mirrors
orchestrated to get andrew weston annie
burnham gmca and tfgm off the hook it
does not address the supply issues for
hevs and it does not give us clean air
you will know the conservative group
over many months have raised concerns
regarding the clean air plan for greater
manchester highlighting time and time
again the lack of any scrutiny the
actual need and the sheer size we're all
supported of clean air in our borough we
have heard we have had no exceedances
which makes this proposal presented
before us tonight to ask for more money
totally inadequate
the repeated mantra mandated from the
government is labor hoodwinking our
residents to be clear
the mayor of gm
andrew weston
gmca and tfgm tasked the government to
approve their plan in march 2019 excuse
me hang on council robin hang on now
councillor jerome did point out that you
should be speaking to the amendments now
are you speaking
seems to me you're speaking to the main
emotion well
are we going to get an opportunity to
speak to the motion
if not if people stick to one minute and
30 seconds and speak and speak to the
amendment as i've asked them to then we
will do that's what i wanted to get back
to council western has the right to
reply
and then we wouldn't then we would take
a vote and then we would move on to
whatever turns out to be the main motion
so we don't normally get excuse me
arguing we don't get the opportunity to
speak to the amount to speak to the main
motions we never have i've had a
conversation with the legal officer
we're not going to get the opportunity
to speak to the amendment i know but
counselor jerome is perfectly right when
he says there's a point of order that
members should be speaking to the
amendment councillor jerome council
evans and those issues that you i've not
heard you mentioned one issue that
counselled your roman council welcome
councillor coggins we're moving in the
amendment
okay so we'll speak to the amendment so
the amendment asked this plan
which will not achieve clean air for it
to go so it will not achieve clean air
and it will punitively punish all our
small businesses in an area of trafford
with no exceedances and the amendment
goes even further to punish people even
further introduce further congestion on
the a56 the amendment is it doesn't even
need considering is that bad so in
speaking to the amendment and i will
expect to be able to speak to the motion
the amendment we will not be supporting
thank you thank you councillor evans
councillor blackburn please
thank you
thank you can i just say that the
amendment doesn't mention the network of
motorways going through greater
manchester
um and council blackburn
you've just said the amendment doesn't
mention the network of motorways please
you need to speak to the amendment mrs
blackburn i know members
we've been relaxed without that in the
past but as councillor jerome pointed
out you need to be speaking to the
amendment that is what the liberal
democrat group moved earlier not the
main motion and i will do my best to get
back to you
agreeing
so can you speak to the amendment please
i'll go back and sit down mr mayor okay
okay councillor morgan
thank you
i'm gonna wait till then okay
so councillor andrew weston's got the
right to reply councillor weston
yeah thanks chair just um very briefly
two reasons why we're unable to support
the amendment one is that we have a
long-standing policy as an
administration where we will not write
blank checks in this council chamber
certainly
if we had costed modelling for some of
the things that had been asked for here
we could have a sensible discussion
about it but in the absence of that it
isn't possible i think the other issue
um is that at this moment in time and
given that only
the um the the secretary of state can
make changes or decide not to make
changes to this at this point i can't
give guarantees that we would be
implementing this
from
the agreed time scale currently clearly
if we remain under a ministerial
direction
as we are currently then we would have
to do that we have no option
despite some of the protestations for
the country that we're already starting
to hear
but that does mean that i cannot give
that cast iron guarantee it is the
current intention because that is how we
are currently legally directed
and so as it stands were we not to do
that we would face the risk of legal
challenge
however
it is for the secretary of state to
ultimately decide what the date of
compliance is and therefore within that
to
enable a joint policy review as per our
substantive motion thanks chair thank
you council western i will now put the
amendment to the vote
all those in favor of the moment of the
amendment please show
hands down and goes against the
amendment police show
i think that's pretty clear hands down
so that amendment has been lost
two abstentions oh sorry i didn't
represent you too can they be recorded
please
okay
since we have no we haven't had
um
substantial discussion we want something
to have some more discussion on the main
motion um
so we'll go back to that the main motion
and council morgan wanted to speak to
that motion
thank you very much sir um the issue
throughout this has been that the plan
both goes too far and not far enough and
creating such a huge zone larger than
any other in the country indeed the
world
and there were other alternatives other
cities have done that targeting the city
centres whether the focus of the problem
this won't this proposed scheme won't
hit a chief executive driving to the
city center each day regardless of
alternatives of public transport that
might be available to him but it will
hit the window cleaner driving a van
from broadhead to sale more
um finally mr uh finally chair on the
original motion why the conservative
group cannot support it it frankly
doesn't go far enough um there needs to
be a full review of this scheme on
whether such a gigantic proposal is a
required but b
more importantly is actually
implementable
so thank you very much thank you very
much
councillor evans you'd like to speak
thank you chair
thank you chair i'll pick up where i
left off the repeated mantra mandated
from the government is labour
hoodwinking of our residents
the mayor of gm andrew weston gmca and
tfgm tasked the government to approve
their plan in march 2019 locking greater
manchester into their only proposed
model which was to make a daily charge
across
493
square miles they asked for 120 million
for their plan they got what they asked
for
basic math says you'd need nearer 2.5
billion for 75 000 non-compliant
vans in gm this doesn't consider
supporting our neighbours to be able to
trade with us inside what will become
greater manchester's own version of the
berlin wall controlled at every turn by
cameras
our concerns have been backed by the
society of motor manufacturers that
ninety percent of light vans were never
going to be retrofittable knowing this
you still forged ahead with the same
plan
and even now this motion is only about
asking for more money
how much money do you think you need to
cover the damage of a 493
square mile charging zone because 120
million is 5
of what you would have needed
i am inundated with heartbreaking
stories from the likes of taxi drivers
sole traders milkmen decorated haulage
companies plumbers joiners and camper
van owners all at their wit's end
many a whole many haulers have had to
deal with a shortage of workers and wage
increases so they really can't afford to
buy a new hundred and fifty thousand
pound truck even with a possible ten
thousand pound grant and a two-year wait
councillor evans you need to wrap up in
the next it's time for this council to
be honest with the businesses and
residents in trafford and it's time for
the leader and the mayor should accept
that this plan will not well doesn't
need to but could never control clean
air and ask the minister to suspend
their plan the plan should be ripped off
it needs
who wants to speak and i'm conscious the
time is five past nine everybody and
we've got another motion to discuss
councillor blackburn
councilman new grosh
and that's it okay councillor
thank you mayor
what is comment generally uh
the 1200 deaths isn't just about that
the biggest one of the concerns as well
which we've raised continually is
effects on younger people whose lungs
have yet to develop and and they're most
at risk particularly as well as people
who are ill and elderly i myself have
lived close to 856 and i've developed
asthma over the many years and as to why
that is
and i think took what i found
interesting when we had the debate last
time and tonight so far i've not heard
one conservative talk about those health
effects their members have but i haven't
heard what one of them i'm standing
affected if someone can speak later and
wish to do that but so far they haven't
done that but now and to be quite clear
to council evans we have been mandated
to introduce such a scheme because of
exceedances it's your your government
was taken to court on numero on three
occasions by client earth and they
failed and they lost that case on three
occasions however rather than deal with
themselves or develop a scheme with
local governments they actually mandated
local councils around the country to
introduce this now each area around the
country has to have a scheme that's
designed to work for their local area
now in in their very also
whilst we have designed a scheme that
that suits one will bring down the next
greater manchester what we do find is
that the government also dictated the
vehicle glasses now you mentioned things
like camper vans and we have some
sympathy for that but that is outside of
air complex your government that put
camper vans in the categories b and c
not not us it's your government that did
that and they told us to introduce them
now
you can shake your head or you want
councillor evans that's quite clear now
at the last month i also asked you to
lobby your government
to actually for extra money for the
hardship fund have you done that i don't
think you have you've made no mention at
all so with that i think that's quite
shocking there's so many things we could
say about this but it is about the
availability of vehicles not just the
price of them there's been a global
national a global shortage
and that has i'll just finish in a
second if i can
and simply say and so when that filters
through the main companies are not
offloading their vehicles therefore they
are not coming onto the second market
that personal price but it's also
affecting availability and they're the
issues that we have to go to we have to
introduce it in time client earth is
waiting counsellor i'd said thank you
council blackburn
one minute and 30 seconds thank you
thank you i'll be very quick um the
proposed clean air zone will never
successfully work in greater manchester
because of the motorway network
threading its way around the communities
the heavy goods vehicles that
are using the motorways 24 hours a day
can continually impact tunnels the
motorways will never disappear and
because of that
uh clean air zone will not be successful
thank you
thank you mr blackburn and councilman
new gross you're going to conclude for
us
i've been asked to mention chair there
isn't a motion after this motion
if that saves a bit of time so um i hope
it goes without saying that lib dems
support the right to breathe clean air
however saying that the number of
contacts i've had from my residents and
on the doorstep
local small traders one van man uh and
women and this is going to destroy their
businesses we have all agreed every
party has agreed that the hardship fund
is not funded enough so
i i think it
doesn't but it doesn't benefit our
residents with this
finger pointing between both the uh
mayor and the national government i the
lib dems call for pause a pause while
both parties sit down and hammer this
out we need a solution that works for
everyone we need it to be supported
financially
and we need it soon
but
it must be right and i'm prepared to
wait for it to be right thank you thank
you councilman
counselor weston you have the right to
reply
yeah thank you
chair there were a number
of comments that i that i will address
in summing up the debate um some range
from inaccuracies through to things that
i
agree with and i will begin with council
ms blackburn who said something that i
very strongly
support which is that we need action on
the motorway network to tackle
the issue of dirty air unfortunately the
government continues to refuse to listen
to the case that is made not just by
ourselves not just by clean air
campaigners but by all councils who are
facing the
same problems that we are here as the
ten boroughs of greater manchester but
you know as with so much of this
government imposes and mandates upon
local authorities without taking action
itself um i want to address the point
about exceedances because it is an
important one and councilor merza made
it very eloquently
the fact of the matter is that modelling
shows that there will be 152 areas of
exceedance in greater manchester in
2024.
we can't argue with that modelling it is
what it is and it is on that basis that
the government has directed us to
introduce a category c clean air zone
across greater manchester now i
recognize that you are legally qualified
councillor merger so you will understand
what a ministerial direction means and
you will importantly because it
addresses some of councillor evans
points about where the ability to change
this sits the wording of the ministerial
direction at 0.9 variation revocation or
suspension and we need to be absolutely
clear about this because this is why
this motion is here tonight forget the
mudslinging forget the attempts to score
political points there is only one
person now
who can allow changes to this scheme and
that is the secretary of state for the
environment george eustis mp and that is
because point nine of the ministerial
direction reads the authorities must not
vary revoke or suspend
their implementation of the local plan
for nitrogen dioxide compliance pursuant
to article 3.
the only person who can enable that to
happen
is the secretary of state and we have
seen some appalling misinformation from
conservatives across greater manchester
including some in this room
that suggests that that is not the case
but that is the ministerial direction
now
i accept that there are challenges with
the current policy
but you said yourself councillor evans
that march 2019 was when this went to
government and we have had the small
matter of a global pandemic since then
that has brought absolute havoc through
supply chains that has led to longer
lockdowns in certain countries that has
impacted on the manufacturing
sector there are certain components that
are not being produced that has impacted
on the ability to procure new vehicles
and in turn therefore driven up prices
in the second-hand market but we can't
go with a feeling in your waters on that
council or evidence we have to look
at producing an evidence base and
greater manchester is the only place in
the country to have done so and the
giant air quality unit are very grateful
to us for that work because it shows
that prices have increased by as much
potentially as 60
and therefore shows that there is a
significant potential problem with this
scheme
and it's not just that it would hit
working people in their pockets but of
course if they are unable to procure new
compliant vehicles it would do so and
that is something that we all want to
avoid but crucially too
it means that our ability to achieve
compliance with this scheme has been
materially impacted by those problems in
the supply chain and we fear that we
will not be able to achieve compliance
as a result so we've tried to be
solution focused here we've tried to put
something to the secretary of state that
says look we've got a problem residents
and businesses are telling us that we
have a problem
we want to work with you to sort this
out but to suggest that we're just
asking for money actually isn't true and
the motion says that we're seeking a
broader policy review and you know
councillor morgan suggested that we
should be going further that's exactly
what we are asking for he also said some
places have just done the city centre
but of course some places aren't the ten
boroughs of greater manchester because a
charging clean air zone in the city
center only
would put bolton berry wiggum trafford
and all of the other boroughs that
aren't manchester
out of step with their ministerial
direction all 10 of us must act and we
do not have a choice on that
if we were to go further than this
without the secretary of state's
approval
then we would be legally challenged
because we would be in breach of that
ministerial direction and that is not a
place that we can go so there is a
solution here and andy burnham met today
with the secretary of state for the
environment which is to get around the
table do that urgent policy review that
councillor morgan and councillor evans
and others were asking for so that we
can come together and come up with a
solution because frankly throw as much
mud as you like but the situation is so
clear now that there is only one person
who can allow this policy to be changed
and i really hope that he listened today
and he listened when i wrote to him last
week thank you chair thank you
councillor weston
i'm now going to put the motion to the
vote
all those in favor of the motion please
show
yet hands down all those against
and the only abstentions
okay thank you
that motion is carried
motion 7d
as you will be aware the motion set out
on the summons 7d also concerns the
greater manchester clean airplane
however
has the council has just passed the
labour group clean air motion unamended
to proceed with a conservative motion
will now contribute contravene
rule 15.3 of the council procedure rules
that rule states a motion which has the
effect of negating a decision made at a
meeting of council within the preceding
six months cannot be moved unless there
is some fresh information or other
change circumstances which justify such
a course
on the basis of that the conservative
motion if passed would effectively
negate the early emotion
it therefore cannot be put forward and
debated
any further
and
my my ruling is my ruling is that that
most that motion cannot be
debated deceiving because it negates the
previous motion
um and
i'm going to invite comments from the
floor councillor evans
i'm just conscious of the time council
everything's quarter past nine now i'll
be very brief
the motion calls for scrutiny which has
been sadly lacking and perhaps we
wouldn't be where we are today if it had
been scrutinized however the last
paragraph of our res resolution um is
the element that causes the problem with
respect to this motion so i i asked
leave that that we may amend are not
amend alter our motion i think the
phrase is and we will remove that last
paragraph which will allow our motion to
be heard which we'll call for scrutiny
and an independent investigation of why
we are where we are thank you mr best
okay so what councilor evans is
proposing he's going to remove the end
of his motion so so that he doesn't
negate the previous motion is that
seconded
thank you
do we have the consent of the council
meeting
council weston
i think there's a challenge here
chair because it was clear to me when i
read the summons that this motion would
not be able to be heard on the basis
that it negated
the motion preceding it and therefore
we've not as a labour group have the
chance to consider our approach to this
motion given the sensitivities of it i
would be extremely uncomfortable with us
hearing it on that basis okay
perhaps i may clarify um
obviously in terms of the negation point
um the mayor has made a determination
and that is not up for debate
council evans is entitled to request
a an alteration to that
motion and which is done in which case
that the vote will be taken in terms of
whether that request is accepted or not
if the consent's given on the majority
then we will go to consider
that motion minus that final point
okay i'm advised that we can with the
removal uh
at the end of that motion of the
conservative group that we can debate it
so i'm going to invite speakers to that
or whether we accept it whether we
accept that alteration thank you
so we've
so we're going to take a vote
see if council is
the leaders talking to council evans for
a moment just bear with me
operations
everybody please
you'll need to suggest it's your motion
mr west
you want to speak council evans come on
then thank you thank you mr mayor uh
right okay it's going to get a bit
messy but i think we've arrived at a
position where what we really need is
some proper scrutiny on this and
potentially an independent investigation
so
um if if i could draw everybody's
attention to our motion item d
first page we're leaving that in
um
top of page two starting this has led
two and finishes states the ames we'd
like to remove that section oh nathan
you've got lose the first paragraph that
says it's misleading
on the other page
frustrating with this council notes
ah right okay page one
we're going to remove misleading for the
time being
right
we're going to remove the the top
paragraph of page two
and we are going to remove the bottom
paragraph of page two
so the motion will start this council is
deeply concerned and it will finish at
tfgm on page one it will start at this
council notes all of the things there
and it will finish at council and the
relevant scrutiny panels one and
hopefully we can then go to debate thank
you
all right
okay
so i hope that's clear to everybody
we're gonna move
you're supposed to tell us
okay
everybody council coggins
thank you chair um i now have two points
of order um first of all we we did
discuss at uh constitutional review
group and agree amongst all four parties
a few years back that we would not be
taking
massive amendments from the floor like
this and
that was for good reason because
residents deserve a well-informed debate
where we've had time to actually talk to
the officers who know the detail on this
and scrutinize the content
before we're asked to vote on anything
it is not right or responsible for
members here to be voting on stuff well
we haven't had an opportunity to read it
in detail to just strike out paragraphs
and not think about the implications or
to talk to the officers who are experts
and the second point of order is that in
the resolutions i think that both points
two
and three they're not numbered but the
second and third bullet points
are outside of the remit of this council
the first one is um informing a gmc
committee to do something it's not
saying the council recommends that they
do it it's asking them to do it
and the third one actually mandates all
of the other gm districts to do
something
and i know in the past we've heard that
we can't mandate
a pension fund for example to do things
and so i think there's two points of
order that concern me about discussing
this motion thank you thank you
okay what we're gonna have to do it's
not clear to everybody what exactly the
conservative group are proposing and
the other issues that councilor cogging
has raised so what we're going to have
to do we have to reconvene a council
meeting to discuss this motion we will
not get through the businesses this is
only five minutes left and we finish at
9 30 this evening
so i'm going to close the meeting i'm
going to ask i'm going to be reminding
you that we will be
reconvening the council meeting whether
we can add it on
to the meeting in february i doubt that
that's the the budget meeting that'll
reconvene between now and
we'll take notice on that and uh and
we'll inform you accordingly
that concludes the meeting everybody
thank you
the officers
okay
so the plan is we're gonna we're gonna
discuss the motion at the budget meeting
we've got some we've got some time there
i'm advised that we can squeeze it in so
we'll be discussing the motion at the
budget meeting in february thank you
everybody
emails